funerals have been held for three
Palestinians in the occupied West Bank
they were killed during an Israeli raid
in the city of nebulous some political
factions are calling for a general
strike in response to the raid the
Ibrahim reports now from Nautilus
as soon as the Israeli Army leaves
nablis Palestinians start counting
they're dead
scene that's becoming all too familiar
in the occupied West Bank
this time three people were killed in
nearly two hours of confrontations
between Palestinian Fighters and
hundreds of Israeli soldiers
I woke up by seven in the morning and
all of a sudden we heard the explosion I
was petrified I could not move an inch
the window glass shattered all over the
house as a result of the explosion my
children and I were forced to the ground
during the raid Israeli forces prevented
medical Crews from entering the city to
treat several people wounded by live
ammunition and school children who had
inhaled tear gas
Ibrahim was our neighbor he was in
pieces and burnt the rest were shot in
the head it was chilling it was hard to
identify them
Israeli forces have been focusing their
raids in nablas and Janine where
Palestinian resistance groups have been
working together to carry out appraisal
attacks
more than 30 Palestinians have been
killed in nablish since the beginning of
the year according to official figures
what
relatively calm here in the past month
we are hearing chance of defiance and
threats of retaliation the Israeli Army
says the Palestinians targeted in
Thursday's raid were responsible for
last month's drive-by shooting in the
Jordan Valley three settlers were killed
a woman and her two daughters they were
identified as dual British Israeli
citizens
the attack follows efforts by the United
States Egypt and Jordan to de-escalate
tensions
Hamas has described the three Fighters
as Heroes and called for more attacks
against Israel the Palestinian Authority
they tested the political choice for a
long time for more than 25 years but
they got big zero so I think this is the
only language that the occupation
understand
in a separate incident Israeli forces
killed a 26 year old woman at a
checkpoint near nablis they say she
stopped the soldier
in recent weeks there have been reports
of members of armed groups handing
themselves over to the Palestinian
Authority people in nabliss say even if
some Fighters have laid down their
weapons others will pick them up
the occupied West Bank
well Israelis are back on the streets to
protest against the government's plan to
overhaul the Judiciary prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu pulls the changes in
March after intense public pressure but
tens of thousands have continued to
protest every week for having Jam June
report now from West Jerusalem
there is one particular protest which is
happening in West Jerusalem just outside
of the president's residence and the
reason that this protest is happening
outside of the residents of the
president of Israel is because the
president has been acting as a mediator
in negotiations that have been ongoing
between prime minister Benjamin
netanyahu's Coalition on the far right
and opposition parties uh these are
talks that are trying to come to some
sort of a compromise when it comes to
these judicial overhaul plans as you'll
recall these plans were put forth by
prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu and
his Coalition Partners they would if
enacted give parliamentarians more power
in appointing Supreme Court justices
they would also give Parliament the
authority to overturn some Supreme Court
decisions that's something that's
concerned a lot of critics here in
Israel a lot of citizens in Israel who
have said that this is something that
would push Israel away from democracy
and more towards autocracy we've also
heard of protests that are going on in
Tel Aviv that there are protesters out
on a highway there and we've also heard
of protests that are in different parts
of the country blocking certain roads
intersections this protest movement that
has sprung up uh in opposition to the
plans to overhaul the Judiciary this has
been unlike anything anybody expected